Michael, je t'ai appris depuis que tu es
enfant, tu as un don que
tu as toujours s'il y a une réponse à
la maladie, nous la trouverons
[Musique]
J'aurais dû mourir il y a longtemps,
pourquoi suis-je toujours là si ce n'est pour réparer ça
J'ai une maladie du sang rare et je
ne suis rien à la fois vidéo
ça pourrait être ma dernière chance
[Musique]
tu prépares quelque chose qu'est-ce que c'est qui
n'est pas exactement l'étiquette
Je veux te voir souffrir plus que tu ne l'
as déjà fait  serait un remède
à quel prix
[Musique]
Je suis passé du temps
[Musique] la
force accrue est la vitesse
[Musique]
la capacité est l'écholocation
et j'ai maîtrisé la terre pour consommer
le sang
[Musique]
jusqu'où sommes-nous autorisés à aller,
nous allons réparer quelque chose  c'est cassé
jusqu'à ce que le remède soit pire que la
maladie
Michael Morbius attentif à faire le
truc du vieux gentil quoi de neuf doc
toi